what is going on I'm here with Brad
Jones aka cinema snob Doug Walker aka
nostalgia critic and me aka me I don't
have a thing you guys have things you
know what you're missing I know we just
saw Ferdinand probably the most
anticipated movie that came out last
weekend myself a children's book which I
have not read I think you read it though
you said right are you I saw the Disney
cartoon and then I was read the story as
a kid from what I remember I could be
right it just
Fernan and likes flowers doesn't like
fighting and then like they mistake him
for like this big killer bowl they put
him in you know the arena and he doesn't
fight he just smells the flower right
and they put it back they don't even do
anything
don't gives it's like oh that's pathetic
if that's the star so really it's an
honest adaptation spoiler alert case you
wanted to see Ferdinand except that
first like they make it look like he's
really obsessed with flowers okay well
that makes sense that's the story and
then they just kind of ditched that
thread for a long time because they
realize he's a Huffer Ferdinand is
voiced by John Cena which I guess for a
lot of people in the studio who made
this was probably like a really
subversive idea like get somebody like
big like that two versus oh yeah he's
fine I think his voice work was was good
the animation is you know pretty nice
it's a blue sky film so it's not Pixar
it's not DreamWorks but it's a great
looking animation it has a positive
message it has all the things you would
expect to see in a movie like this it
has pretty good music I would say was
was fine the voice work is all it's all
good it's like a serviceable movie that
I'm sure kids will probably go to and
enjoy watching but it's it's it's
lacking in regards to any real depth and
one of my biggest issues is that the
most important relationship I would say
in this movie is the little girl and
Ferdinand because you're supposed to
care yeah it's even the poster yeah and
it's so throwaway because it starts out
with him
this place where they train bulls to be
fought or they go to the Chop House and
die and he's a little bull but
eventually and he winds up as an adult
right back in that same place again and
there's just this little time period in
between those two visits with this girl
on this farm where he's smelling the
flowers and enjoying life and he just
don't really feel that connection really
which i think was kind of a missed
opportunity they kind of just ditch her
and you know why couldn't it go back to
her kind of missing him or her saying
I'm gonna go find him or you know maybe
even a little bit of her adventure while
his adventure is going on or say you
know something creating that connection
because that was the only time I felt
any connection to anyone because
everything else is so not awful but it's
very cookie cutter because then her
plotline when she's off screen the movie
Charlotte's Web is happy that's what
she's doing she's falling in love with
the you know a great pig yeah there just
wasn't enough set up so to really give a
about them no I mean it's it's a
movie that through a lot of it through
myself just kind of being tired while we
were watching it through a lot of it I
was I was this close to nodding off and
I wasn't really blaming the movie for as
I was like I think I would probably be
like this regardless of what I was
watching there would be like little
20-minute chunks where I I was like okay
some of this is a little heartfelt
especially at the beginning especially
in the first 15 minutes when we see
Ferdinand as the the baby bull and
everything with him and the bullies in
this relationship with this with this
girl and he loses his dad at the
beginning that dad I thought was nice
like I agree with you that was probably
the better president yeah and when it
gets to him being older it's a lot of
like kind of easy jokes that you see in
the trailer and things like that we're
not that they were like really groaners
but they were jokes you would just sort
of expect in a movie like this come on
they're in a convertible yeah exactly
but then every 20 minutes every maybe
every 15 or 20 minutes something would
happen that would kind of snap me awake
or make me really laugh out loud
I was never consistently laughing in
this but something would
get me like at least a couple times and
act in this film sure the part with the
the eyelid yeah this one bulb decapitate
to fly with its eyelid and I think all
of us just yeah I was it was like he's
like a Frankenstein bull Franken bold
yeah yeah they say he's created in a lab
or whatever he seems to be able to like
control electricity by rubbing his
hooves together which is interesting
he's importantly fine with electrocuting
himself on the fence and it doesn't
affect ya so he's like this strange
creature I'm not sure what he is really
the strange where they Swedish or German
as you say like yeah yeah I was gonna
say did you love the dance fighting
scene because I didn't at first no but
again so once in a while there was a
funny pose or when the crazy fool will
come in and every part of his body would
move except his head like sometimes that
strange animation would make it work a
little bit but yeah when you hear like
you know the pop music playing it's like
oh this bullcrap
okay well I'll take that over because I
kind of liked any time the horses showed
up it was it was sort of the same joke
every time but it was a joke that I was
enjoying and I'll yeah there is that
dance-off but the bullet works very
clear but come on are you at all
surprised I'll take that over the thing
that you see in about 80% of kids movies
like this or suddenly they'll be this
big even if the movies not a musical
they'll just be this big musical there
at the ending credits or silly like yeah
like some like animal pop singer like it
and that doesn't happen here so I kind
of respected that but it happened in the
middle yeah they got it over with so
much sooner
thoughts on Kate MacKinnon's goat oh oh
is that who that yes I was I think like
everyone in this movie all I'm doing and
I think a lot of it does come down to
direction you just need to give them
better material you have to know when to
say okay this improv keeping this
out and I like a lot of people just
going who is that who's that voice is it
this person no is it this person now and
just half the cast I'm just doing that
and I think that rather than like
excited like who is this print like
they're so funny and they're making me
laugh you know again that just seems
like one where the jokes aren't that
great and by god they're trying I mean I
can't act like oh they're just phoning
it in like the really try they're just
they don't have an understanding of what
the character is I I knew it was her
right away because it's again Kate
McKinnon being weird and crazy because
just cuz I feel like she can be really
funny but again you need us Saturday
Night Live yeah honestly Kay mckennon's
a comedic genius she is I mean when you
really think about it she goes out there
once a week and just like pulls all the
CM out of her and it's it's incredible
and she she has some lines in here that
I think are funny she has her voice
delivery is good she's funny but it's
just one of those things like you said
whether the material just it's
serviceable this is not the type of
animation and I think there's a reason
it was it was put out the same week and
a Star Wars you know it's like here it's
not Norma the North this isn't the emoji
movie no the road ship for three you
know yeah there's nothing like that this
is a movie that as you said kids are
gonna go to and be like yeah that was
fun but you're not gonna like probably
watch it over and over again it's yeah
yeah you know and I think this is fine
for kids there's no bad messages there's
nothing that you know for anything like
that
a kid can go see this laugh at the
animation the bright colors get a good
message little things like that you know
and that's all it's a little you know
hour and a half to keep your kids quiet
like that that's about it I was kind of
watching bully for bugs in my head after
I showed you just came out it I was so
waiting for doo-doo-doo doo-doo-doo-doo
[Music]
and I'm like see that's kind of a
failure to the film cuz I'm like how is
it I didn't once think of that this film
somehow I know I could blame me but it's
like now I'm fit blaming the the whole
bullfighting aspect of the movie - it
just you could see where it was all
going you knew that as soon as this this
master bullfighter came to this farm
that he was observing them and you okay
eventually it's gonna be Ferdinand and
you know there's gonna be a big finale
where they have a thing and he has to
not fight and prove his worth you know
and obviously the message is you can be
different and it's fine you don't have
to do what everyone expects you to do
which is 9 out of 10 of family movies
yeah yeah I think I'm complaining about
I'm not being an asshole about its
Ferdinand you know it's kids are gonna
go and they're gonna have fun and it's
not insufferable the voice work is
separable yes and it's way better than
what we watched last night this is the
better movie that we it is much better
than a Christmas story like fairy you
did have the better recommendation oh my
god well yeah Ferdinand it's an animated
movie with a ball I guess if I'm gonna
graze I'm gonna get Ferdinand to C plus
C yeah I'm with you I was thinking C+ as
well it did get me a few times
kate mckinnon the goat I thought was
annoying but other than that it's
exactly what you said I'm never sitting
there pulling my hair out her we've seen
worse kids movies this year by freaking
far this just it it's it's serviceable
yeah I saw this there is a ball I think
it's time for all of us to go to bed
but guys if you haven't checked out Doug
Walker you can check out channel awesome
there's a link in the description below
if you haven't checked out Brad Jones
there's also a link for his channel guys
thanks so much for joining me on this I
really appreciate it thank you yeah
thank you for not making as much
Christmas yeah
that's my job yeah but yeah we're gonna
be doing a cool collaboration soon on
channel awesome for something that also
came out last weekend and that'll be up
over at that channel next Wednesday you
think yes that is the plan thank you so
much as always for watching if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]